all right everybody we're back with tom
hanks and in the uh commercial break he
drove his scooter in here and we're
ready to go
i don't know why we didn't start outside
but this is what we're doing what i
learned in the test is you got to wear a
helmet okay
so put it on okay and then just pick up
the chicks
all right here we go let's go let's get
out of here all right here we go
[Applause]
hey you better slow down the gates down
okay whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa i'm
gonna need to see some id
okay i uh gee uh i forgot mine
all right yeah a little slow with the
both of us on really slow
is not what we thought it would be hey
uh hey dodgers are in town what are you
saying i love baseball let's go
let's go let's go oh here we are
oh yeah oh man oh we're up in the cheeks
look at that oh nose bleeding yeah
[Applause]
get some peanuts there okay very nice
peanuts
thanks i got him
hey everybody want some peanuts hey
peanuts
here you go man
[Applause]
cool hey i'll do it too hey you want
some peanuts
yeah oh back here
let's head on down to the front let's go
down the field
hey it's andre eat there hey look hey
tom hey coco
let's see what you got okay hey here you
go my man
ready ready and up
oh i gotta go this way
hey i got an idea let's uh let's go to
hollywood boulevard okay let's go
[Applause]
never would have happened to buzz
lightyear
all right hey this scooter is getting
pretty dirty oh yeah hey there's a car
wash right over here
ready yeah here put on here
[Applause]
[Applause]
well yeah it is a clean bike
now this is yeah right there hey uh hey
there's your car
there yeah hey let's go to the uh you
know what's near here the la branch
river
i've never been oh but let's go
oh dinosaurs look at that prehistoric
beasts a mastodon
and look guess what here comes
prehistoric man right here check it out
[Applause]
get
[Applause]
hey tom i think you uh think you made a
wrong turn oh no it's gonna be fine
[Applause]
oh my god tom hanks everybody